ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีนักเรียนด้วยสวัสดีครับเย้หน้ากลับ
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกับพี่อาร์ตี้แหละน้อง
เรียมกันนะครับโอเค
วันนี้แล้วถ้าเขาที่แล้วใช่ไหมที่เราเก็บ
กระเป๋ากันเราเก็บกระเป๋ากันเราจะไปไปไหน
ครับอ๋อไปยังใหม่
แถวว่าวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับที่เรานัด
กันไว้ที่เราจะไปเชียงใหม่
วันนี้วันที่ 21 ถ.วันนี้ที่วันที่ 21 นะ
เป็นวันอังคารเป็นวันอังคารได้วันอังคาร
ที่ 21 เดือน
เดือนกันยายนกันยายนโอเคปี
คศคริสตศักราช 2013
4  21  11 นะคะโอเค
คศ 2000  21  5 วันนี้วันที่โหวันนี้ก็
วันที่ 21 ด้วย
ขอ
ช21โอเคเหมือนกันเลยโอเค
5 เดี๋ยววันนี้เราจะไปเที่ยงใหม่กันนะ
ครับโอเคแล้วจะไปเชียงใหม่เนี่ยหาเขาที่
แล้วที่เราเก็บกระเป๋าเดินทางไว้แล้วเรา
จะไปเชียงใหม่ค่ะเชียงใหม่อยู่
แล้วไม่เกี่ยวกระเป๋าใบใหญ่มากเลยใส่
เสื้อผ้าไปเยอะแน่นอนใส่เสื้อผ้าไปเยอะ
ว่าจะไปเที่ยวหลายที่ใช่ไหมงั้นไงค่ะเฮีย
ตีเก็บเป็นกระเป๋าใบเล็ก
บายเล็กๆ
ใช้กับใบเล็กๆอ้ะเชียงใหม่อยู่ทางภาค
เหนือนะ
มาอยู่อยู่ข้างเหลือเราจะเดินทางจากที่
นี่ไปที่เชียงใหม่นี่เชียงใหม่อยู่ตรงนี้
เดี๋ยวนะพี่เปลี่ยนสีปากกาก่อนมันมองไม่
เห็นนี่เชียงใหม่อยู่ตรงนี้
เชียงใหม่อยู่ตรงนี้
เราจะไปเชียงใหม่แล้วเราจะไปยังไงดีครับ
ไปเชียงใหม่
อาไปเชียงใหม่ไปได้หลายทางครับไปได้หลาย
ทางแตกทางแรกที่พี่เอ็ดดี้จะอ่ามาพานัก
เรียนแล้วก็น้องเรียนไปด้วยกันก็คือเรา
อาจจะขับรถไป
นะครับไปใช่ครับอ่านี่นี่ครับเราขับรถคัน
นิดให้เธอแล้วมันบางโอเคขับรถคันนี้ฮ่าๆ
ขับรถคันนี้ไปเห็นนะครับอ่าน้องต้องอ่าน
น้องเรียมขับรถเป็นไหมขับรถเป็นไหมขับรถ
เป็นค่ะอ๋อเตรียมก็ขับรถเยอะตีก็ขับรถ
เป็นเผื่อตอนที่เราขับรถไปเนี่ยพี่อาจจะ
ง่วงผู้สอนอาจจะไม่แล้วเดี๋ยวให้น้อง
เรียมมาช่วยขับนะอ่าเขา
ได้ค่ะได้ได้นะโอเคได้ๆๆแล้วก็ยกก่อนที่
เราจะไปเนี่ยก่อนที่เราจะขับรถเราต้องไป
เติมน้ำมันก่อน
ต้องไปเติมน้ำมันที่ไหนไอ้ครับเติมน้ำมัน
ใส่เข้าไปในรถน้ำมันเนี่ยเราต้องไปเติม
ที่ปั๊มน้ำมันน้านี้ครับเราต้องไปเติมน้ำ
มันที่ปั๊มน้ำมันเวลาที่เรามาถึงปั๊มน้ำ
มันแล้วมีครับเราขับรถเข้าไปในปั๊มน้ำมัน
หาใช่ครับใช่ครับนี่ครับรถเติมน้ำมันใส่
เข้าไปในรถ
ห่าจะมีเด็กปั๊มมีมาเติมน้ำมันให้เราเติม
น้ำมันใส่ไปในรถนะฮะ 5 เติมน้ำมันให้เต็ม
ถังเฮ้ยเฮ้ยเติมน้ำมันให้เต็มถังเพื่อเรา
จะได้ขับไปถึงเชียงใหม่ใกล้ๆรถพี่เติมน้ำ
มันเต็มถังเช้ากี่บาท 100 เปียตีเติมน้ำ
มันเต็มถัง
1,000 บาท 500 บาท
5  1,000 บาท 500 บาท
หน้า 1,500 บาท
อยากเป็นทางเลยให้ครับเต็มถัง 1,500 บาท
ป้ายถึงเชียงใหม่เลย
ร้อนเติมครั้งเดียวได้ครับ
เชียงใหม่หมดพอดี
ถึงเชียงใหม่หมดถังพอดีอ่าโอเค
ไปเติมอีกไปเติมยังใหม่ซ้ายครับอ้อเดี๋ยว
นะ 5 ก่อนที่เราจะขับรถเราต้องมีใบขอขี่
ด้วยใบขับขี่อ่ะใบขับขี่แบบนี้ครับนี่มี
ใบขับขี่แบบนี้ใบขับขี่ที่อนุญาตให้เรา
ขับรถได้ตี้มีใบขับขี่เนี่ยตีขับรถ
ได้น้องเรียงมีใบขับขี่ไหมครับ
เรียงก็มีใบขับขี่ขอ
ครับขี่รถมอเตอร์ไซค์ไปขับขี่รถ
มอเตอร์ไซค์อ่าอีกใบขับขี่รถยนต์โอเคอ่ะ
เพื่อตีก็มีมั้ยขับขี่รถยนต์แล้วก็มีใบ
ขับขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ด้วยเหมือนกันเน๊อะอ่า
แล้วนักเรียนแล้วครับนักเรียนมีใบขับขี่
ไหมครับถ้ามีใบขับขี่รถยนต์หรือใบขับขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ครับนักเรียนนะฮ่าๆมีไหมมีไหม
ถ้ามีคีย์บอกพี่อาร์ตี้ด้วยนะครับนะพี่จะ
ได้รู้โอเคเราตอนนี้เราพร้อมหรือยังก็
พร้อมที่จะไปแล้วค่ะหน้าพร้อมแล้วใช่ไหม
เรามีน้ำมันเต็มถังแล้วมีใบขับขี่แล้วต่อ
ไปเราก็จะขับรถไปเที่ยงใหม่กันได้แล้ว
แล้วก็ฮะขับรถไปเชียงใหม่เนี่ยเราต้องขับ
รถไปตามถนน
ไปตามถนนแบบนี้ขับรถไปตามถนนไปเทียงใหม่
อ่ะ
ขอแค่นี้คือถนนถนน
ทางไปเชียงใหม่มันโค้งชายมีทางโค้งทาง
โค้งโค้งไปโค้งมานี่ทางโค้งเนี่ยนะพี่
อาร์ตี้เปลี่ยนสีปากกาเป็นสีแดงมีทางโค้ง
โค้งโค้งๆ
เพราะว่าที่เที่ยงใหม่มีภูเขา
มีภูเขาที่เชียงใหม่อ่ะภูเขาเชียงใหม่มี
ภูเขาไหมเนี่ยเดินทางก็จะโค้งโค้งขึ้นไป
บนภูเขาอ้าแบบนี้ขับได้ไหมน้องเรียมขับ
คิดว่าเขาได้ไหมเขาจะให้นะได้โอเคไปงั้น
เดี๋ยวเราไปกันแต่ว่าถ้าไปเชียงใหม่มัน
อาจจะขับรถนานนักก็เชียงใหม่อยู่ไกล
เชียงใหม่อยู่ใกล้อาจจะใช้เวลานาน
แล้วใช้เวลานาน
อ๋อใช้เวลานานประมาณ 7 ชั่วโมง
7 ชั่วโมง
ห้า
ใช่ครับ 7 ชั่วโมง
หา
นานเลยใช่ไหม 7 ชั่วโมงถ้าเราออกจาก
บ้านออกจากกรุงเทพตอน
7:00 นหมอตอน 7:00 น
อันนี้ก็จะเป็น 1  2
3  4  5  6  7 เราก็จะมาถึงที่เชียงใหม่
ตอน 14:00 น
อ่า
ที่ยังใหม่บ่าย 14:00 นโอเค
นานไหม
หน้านั้นโอเคน้องเรียมก็นอนไปเลยนอนไป
หนึ่งทดเลยเดี๋ยวพี่อ่ะพี่จะขับ
ได้ที่แอบชั่วโมงโมงเตรียมก็นอน 7
ชั่วโมงชั่วโมง
นอนเลยแม่แต่ถ้าเราไม่อยากไม่อยากขับเอง
ถ้าเราไม่อยากกลับ xd เขาก็ไปเชียงใหม่
ได้เหมือนกันเราก็ต้องไปเอ่อด้วยเต็มที่
อื่นหน้าเราไป
มีวิธีไหนหรอ
เราลองไปรถไฟกันไหมรถไฟนักเรียนรู้จักรถ
ไปไหม
รู้จักค่ะรถไฟนี่รถไฟเป็นแบบนี้ครับนี่
นี่คือไปอ้ะรถไฟของประเทศไทยนะครับหน้าตา
น่ารักแบบนี้เลยเฮ้ย
รถไปของเรานะครับแต่ถ้าไปรถไฟเนี่ยถ้าไป
รถไฟเนี่ยเราจะต้องเราจะต้องไปจองตั๋วรถ
ไฟก่อนนะเพราะว่าเราไม่ได้ขับไปเองเรา
ต้องไปกับรถไฟเราต้องไปจองรถไฟว่าเราจะไป
รถไฟเราต้องไปบอกเขาต้องโทรไปบอกแล้วว่า
เราจะไปแล้วค่อยว่าด้วยเนี่ยต้องโทรไปต่อ
มๆๆครับโทรไปจองรถไฟเพื่อที่จะซื้อตั๋ว
เนื้อหาซื้อตั๋วรถไฟตั๋วรถไฟก็คือก็คือ
ตั๋วที่ใช้จองรถไฟนี่ตั๋วรถไฟจะหน้าตาแบบ
นี้นะนี่เป็นตั๋วรถไฟ
ตั๋วรถไฟบอกอะไรบ้างคะหัวรถไฟก็จะบอกวัน
ที่วันที่รถไฟจะไปจากกรุงเทพฯจะไป
เชียงใหม่นะครับจะไปวันไหนวันนี้ไปวันที่
12 กันยายน 12 กันยายนนะครับ 5 ปีเรา
ต้องดูให้เป็นปีที่เราอยู่นะปีห่า
2021 นะโอเคแล้วก็มีเวลาด้วยจะบอกเวลา
ที่หน้าเวลาที่รถไฟจะออกจากกรุงเทพฯแล้ว
เราต้องไปไปให้ทันเวลานะอ่ะไปให้เวลาที่
เราจองรถไปมีเวลาที่เราจะออกแล้วก็เวลา
ที่ไปถึงเชียงใหม่กี่โมง
ชายอันนี้ก็คือตั๋วรถไฟถ้าเราต้องไปจอโทร
ไปจ่อและถึงเวลา
ตั๋วรถไฟแพงไหมคะพี่ขอตั๋วรถไฟก็จะไม่แพง
ตัวรถไฟประมาณ 500 บาท
500 บาทใช่ครับประมาณ
500 บาท
5  500 บาทเมื่อกี้ถ้าเราขับรถไปเอง
เพราะขับรถไปเองเราเติมน้ำมัน 1,500 บาท
ใช่ไหมอ้าวรถไฟถูกกว่ารถไฟถูกกว่า
หน้าและไม่ต้องขับเองด้วยอ่าแต่แต่
ว่า
รถไปใช้เวลานาน
[เพลง]
กว่า
ฟังแล้ว
นานมากจริงๆแก้ไขเป็น R
ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
นานมากนอนไปแล้วก็นอนอีกเนาะแล้ว
12 ชั่วโมง
นานมาก
โอเคเดี๋ยวพี่มีมีทางอื่นไหมมีทางอื่นไหม
หรอ
เดี๋ยวนะมีทางอื่นไหมรถไฟปกติเนี่ยออถ้า
เราไม่อยากไปรถไฟเราก็ไปรถทัวร์ได้ครับ 5
โอเคถ้าเราไม่อยากไปรถไฟเราไม่อยากไปรถไฟ
พอรถไฟใช้เวลานานใช่มั้ยอ้ะเราก็ไปรถโดย
สารประจำทางได้รถโดยสารประจำทางนี่มีหน้า
ตาแบบนี้เลยเคยเห็นไหมเวียร์เคยเห็นค่ะ
ไม่เห็นประจำทางแบบนี้นะครับเตรียมเคย
เห็นแต่เตรียมเรียกว่ารถทัวร์ฮ่อเรียกว่า
รถทัวร์ใช่ไหมเหมือนกันรถทัวร์หรือว่ารถ
โดยสารประจำทางเหมือนกันหน้าคนไทยก็จะ
เรียกรถทัวร์บางครั้งก็เรียกว่ารถทัวร์
บางครั้งก็เรียกว่ารถบริษัทรถโดยสารประจำ
ทางชื่อมันยาวที่มันยาวคนไทยไม่ชอบเรียก
ชื่อยาวคนไทยชอบเรียกชื่อสั้นๆเป็นชื่อ
เล่นเป็นชื่อเล่นคนไทยชอบเรียกชื่อเล่น
ป่ะนั้นรถโดยสารประจำทางก็มีชื่อเล่นชื่อ
เล่นว่ารถทัวร์รถทัวร์ไปรถทัวร์รถทัวร์ก็
ไปเชียงใหม่ได้รถทัวร์ไปเชียงใหม่ใช้เวลา
น้อยกว่ารถไฟ
ใช้เวลากี่ชั่วโมงค่ะรถทัวร์ใช้เวลา
ประมาณประมาณ
ตีสิบช่วงโหง
[เพลง]
ถ้าเป็นรถตัวเออไหวไหมไหวไหมน้าหลานมาก
อย่างนานอยู่ใช่ไหมอ๋อข้านานแบบนี้เดี๋ยว
นะถ้าไปรถทัวร์เนี่ยก็ใช้เวลาน้อยกว่ารถ
ไฟแต่ก็ยังใช้เวลามากกว่าขับรถไปเอง
เพราะขับรถไปเองเราเรากำหนดความเร็วได้
ว่าเราจะขับเร็วหรือขับหาอ่า
เครียดดิขับรถเร็วไหมคะพี่ขับรถไม่เร็ว
เพียงที่ขับรถปัน
อ๊อดตอบรถไหมแล้วปกติปกติแล้วประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยอนุญาตให้ขับรถเร็วได้เท่ากับ
110  KM
และ
ก็ชั่วโมง
อ่าแอปปกติพี่อาร์ตี้จะขับรถ
ถ้าขับรถไปไกลๆขับรถไกลๆ
ทางไปไกลเพียงตี้ก็จะขับอยู่ประมาณ
กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงอ่ะอันนี้ไม่ดีไม่ควร
ทำผิดกฎหมาย 5 แบบนี้โดนตำรวจจับโดนจับ
เลยไม่ดีไม่ดีน่าจะพอเจอตำรวจที่ Arty ก็
จะขับพอเพียงที่เห็นเห็นตำรวจเพื่อตีก็จะ
ขับ 1 หรอฮะ
โอเค
ดีเห็นเฮียตีเห็นตำรวจตำรวจ
เอาไว้อ้ายปะขับ 100 บาทค้า
โอเคแล้วนักเรียนนักเรียนขับรถเร็วไหม
ครับขับรถเร็วไม่นักเรียนเวลานักเรียน
เห็นตำรวจทุเรียนเข้าเช้าไหมหรือขอบเร็ว
เหมือนเดิม
Are  OK
อ้าวเมื่อกี้เรา
ขับรถใช่ไหมเรานั่งรถใช่ไหมนั่งรถ
ทัวร์ถ้าเราจะไปแล้วครัวเนี่ยเราต้องไป
ขึ้นรถทัวร์ที่
สถานี 5 สถานีขนใช่เพราะว่ารถทัวร์ไม่ได้
อยู่ที่บ้านเราถ้าเราขับรถไปเองรถจอดอยู่
ในโรงจอดรถที่บ้านเราแล้วไปได้เลยแต่ถ้า
เราจะไปรถทัวร์เนี่ยเราต้องไปที่สถานีขน
ส่งใช่นี่เป็นสถานีขนส่งที่มีรถทัวร์จอด
อยู่เยอะๆมีรถโดยสารประจำทางจะหายทันต่อ
ที่นั่นเราต้องไปที่นี่ครับหน้าไปขึ้นรถ
ทานนี่สถานีขนส่งอยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯอยู่ๆแถว
ไหนคะสถานีขนส่งอยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯอยู่แถว
สวนจตุจักรนักเรียนรู้จักสวนจตุจักรไหม
ครับ
สวนจตุจักรต้องรู้จักขออ่ะมีนักเรียนที่
มาจากต่างประเทศจะมาเที่ยวที่สวนจตุจักร
เยอะน่ะบริเวณนั้นก็จะมีสถานีขนส่งอยู่
ด้วยอยู่ใกล้ๆไม่ๆกันใช่ครับใช้ครับน้า
เราก็ต้องไปขึ้นรถที่สถานีขนส่งเพื่อที่
จะไปเชียงใหม่น่าใช้เวลา
8 ชั่วโมง
8 ชั่วโมงชั่วโมงยังนานนานไปใช่ไหมอ่า
น้องเรียวไม่อยากไม่อยากนอนหลับแอบถ่าย
ข้างบนถั่วถ้างั้นเฮียตี้มีอีกวิธีหนึ่ง
ที่เราจะไปได้เร็วกว่าอ่ะไปได้เร็วกว่า
มากอย่าคิดไปยังไงคะออกไหมไปยังไงไปยังไง
อ่า
เราก็ต้องไป
เครื่องบินหน้าไปเครื่องบินบินไปอ่านั่ง
เครื่องบินไปอ้อแต่ถ้าเราจะไปเครื่องบิน
เนี่ยเราก็ต้องโทรไปจองเหมือนกันนะโทรไป
จองใช่ครับไปจองไปบอกเขาว่าเราจะไปด้วย
เราจะไปด้วยต้องโทรไปจอง
โทรไปจองตั๋วเครื่องบิน
โทรไปจองนี้ครับไปจองตั๋วเครื่องบินแบบ
นี้แน่ในตั๋วเครื่องบินก็จะบอกว่าไปวัน
ไหนไปวันไหนวันที่เราจะไปวันที่เท่าไหร่
เวลา
เวลาอะไรการที่เราจะไปใช่ครับอ่ะแล้วก็ใน
ตั๋วเครื่องบินก็จะบอกด้วยว่าเราจะไปนั่ง
ที่ไหนนั่งที่ไหนบนเครื่องบินนั่งตรงไหน
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้ตรงนี้หรือตรงนี้หรือตรงนี้
ตรงนีั้บนตั๋วเครื่องบินที่เราจองเขาจะ
บอกไว้หน้าเราต้องไปมากที่นั่นๆใช้ครับ
แล้วเวลาที่เราจะไปเครื่องบินเราก็ต้องไป
ขึ้นเครื่องบินที่ไหนครับ
ขึ้นที่สนามที่ไหนสถานีขนส่งแล้วนะ
เราต้องไปขึ้นที่สนามบินหน้าเครื่องบิน
ที่สนามบินนะครับๆจากนั้นเราก็บินไต่นั่ง
เครื่องบินบินไปเชียงใหม่บินไปเชียงใหม่
ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่รู้ไหมครับเท่าไหร่ค่ะพี่
ไปเชียงใหม่ใช้เวลาอีกสามสิบนาที
ตา 30 นาทีใช่ครับ 30 นาทีเร็วไหม
เร็วมากใช้กับเครื่องบินบินเร็วมาก
เครื่องบินบิน
เฮียตีขับรถอ่ะ 100 ใช่ไหม
100 กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงอ่ะแต่เครื่องบิน
เครื่องบินบินอยู่ที่ความเร็ว
กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงครับหน้ามันก็เลยเร็ว
กว่ามากเร็วขวางมากๆใช้เขาสิเรียมโทร
สวัสดีค่ะออกจองตั๋วเครื่องบิน
ไปเชียงใหม่ค่ะ
เชียงใหม่จะได้ไปถึงเร็วๆมีเนื้อหาดีครับ
ดีครับเออ
[เพลง]
แล้วตอนนี้เราก็ถึงเชียงใหม่แล้วเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้านะครับเราจะไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่อะ
ที่ไหนกันบ้างเดี๋ยวมาติดตามกันบทเรียน
หน้าว่าเบียร์ตี้กับนักเรียนมจะไปเที่ยว
ที่ไหนกันในเชียงใหม่อ่ะตอนนี้ป่ะถึง
เชียงใหม่นะครับโอเคตื่นเต้นไหมกินเล่นรอ
เต้นรอติดตามรอป 5 ก้าวหน้าโอเค
ด้วยกันในคลิปหน้านะคะแค่ครับสำหรับวัน
นี้อ่าสวัสดีครับสวัสดีน้องเรียมตัวดีนัก
เรียนด้วยครับบ๊ายบาย
หน้าไปเที่ยวเชียงใหม่ใจเที่ยวเชียงใหม่
ค่าตัว 2 ใบค่ะเพราะโอเคอ่า
ม.ค